le principe de la cavale c'est de se
faire discret du moins c'est ce qu'on
pensait ce n'est visiblement pas la
stratégie de raglan le dogue un
influenceur très présent sur tik tok qui
a décidé de publier à ses abonnés des
vidéos de son quotidien de fugitifs en
train de jouer au monopoly avec la femme
par exemple moi et ma forme ans alors
c'est dans une partie de monopoly les
vidéos vues plus de cent mille fois pour
certaines d'entre elles
l'influent soeur un belge de 35 ans est
recherché pour purger sa peine en raison
de plusieurs braquages de bijouteries
l'homme s'est finalement rendue le 2
mars dernier aux autorités
et là encore il l'a fait en direct sur
tik tok dans une semaine précisément je
me rends je devrais que quelques tâches
administratif et donne un coup de main à
ma compagne avant de me rendre un petit
jeu qui à défaut d'amuser les policiers
a beaucoup fait rire ses abonnés alors
type coque aurait-il dû censurer son
compte
ce serait pas mal alors oui bien sûr que
non ce gars là il a fait en tout dix ans
de prison il en reste deux et il dit ne
faites pas comme moi temps explique tout
le monde a le droit à une deuxième
chance est d'accord il le fait en direct
c'est formidable moi j'espère que ça
deviendrait une star des réseaux après
parce qu'il ya quelque chose de bien en
lui il faut pas le condamner franchement
jamais un jeu d'accord c'est vrai que
mais bon en plus il dit je vais me
renvoie là il reste que lui il risque
deux ans il a payé quand même large
largement une partie de sa dette
et il est plutôt sympathique alors j'ai
presque il avait fait par le passé dans
tous les cas ils méritaient pas d'être
censuré c'est effectivement tik tok peut
lui offrir une deuxième chance et voir à
un boulot why not
bon j'ai ri mais les gars on n'est pas
en train de parler de juger ce qu'il a
ses six garçons
il n'y a pas de souci avec ces garçons
il fait ce qu'il veut de sa vie mais
l'on la question ses vis-à-vis des
réseaux sociaux
est-ce qu'ils ont raison ou pas de le
censurer eh ben le réseau social ou oui
il aurait dû le censurer pourquoi me
censure bigard sur la liberté
d'expression canticum ils censurent des
personnes qui n'ont pas mérité
là quand on entre un truc comme ça le
mec est hors la loi no fonsorbes jour où
le titre e.on ses propos moi j'ai rien
contre ce garçon jeu il fait ce qu'il
veut au contraire qui kiffent même mais
on ne montre pas ça sur les réseaux le
réseau social doit le doigt le censurer
comme on sent sur d'autres personnes qui
ne mérite pas et qui s'exprime tout
simplement du collage et vous êtes
devenu fou sérieux ou quoi quoique
le risque est donc qu'il est arrivé dans
l'achat de ces enfants qui sont en train
de faire un foot non mais vous êtes
devenus fous c'est exactement ça donne
dos des tigres ou là où soupçonnent là
oui qu'est-ce qui leur est qui est en
cavale depuis deux ans vous trouvez que
c'est un exemple à montrer que le mail
vous explique comment il faut se cacher
ce qu'il faut faire ce qu'ils m'ont pas
faire enfin c'est affligeant c'est
scandaleux
il n'aurait jamais dû oui c'est autant d
de deux possibilités de s'exprimer je
suis désolé et fonce le nom des réseaux
sociaux c'est censé être un espace de
liberté d'expression donc non il ne faut
pas le censurer il a pas été censuré par
la télé non plus il ya la chaîne belge
rtl qui a fait un reportage sur lui
tranquille dans la rue il portait son
masque en disant qu'il était en cavale
donc si les passants sur à la télé
pourquoi et réseaux préférant tout sera
clair là dessus parce que vous
m'emmerdez mais enfin kelly vous vous
inquiétez une jeune femme de notre temps
c'est un troyen dirait que vous êtes
complètement rétrograde hisser une
cadrée il est parfois j'ai évolué il est
parole du réseau sa cervelle d'oiseau
sociale a bien fait la cac et moi je dis
ce qu'il dit sur le réseau social est
extraordinaire résigné ceni le faites
pas comme moi il profite du réseau pour
dire aux jeunes téléspectateurs vous
m'emmerdez oui à 57 % à y changer